bill I guess this is a point where you
smooth things out i'm looking at a three
months moving average of a hundred and
forty-seven thousand i guess that that
stabilizes the shock that we saw last
month yeah i think so you know the fed
statement last month and the minute
suggested employment uncertainty and as
you smooth things out for three months
at you know close to 150,000 i think
that does it I mean the unemployment
rate went up to the 49 did it not the
wages increased by a point one as
opposed to a point to and so I think
things are not as hunky dory as 280,000
might suggest but you know back to
normalize 150,000 I think that's nothing
to get excited about it may not be
something to get excited about but does
it get anyone interested in what Janet
Yellen and company are going to do does
this change the calculation of when they
might move at all for you no I don't
think so you know they still a brexit to
look into the eyes the whites of the
brexit sighs I guess there are problems
with Italian banks or the Fed doesn't
but the the ECB and the EU do the
problems with the UK property mutual
funds you know there's a sense of
illiquidity and markets and the Fed of
course is very obsessed and concerned
with markets and it's an extent that
there's discord around the world you
know I think the Fed stays where it is
they they've wanted to raise interest
rates they did it once I think they want
to have us believe that they'll raise
several times and therefore have a
pretty positive yield curve which will
help banks and insurance companies but
for the most part I don't think this
changes much